[Music]
[Laughter]
hey everybody
happy memorial day yeah we're back i
mean at least if you're in the u.s
it's not really memorial day in other
countries but whatever whatever no we're
[ __ ] sleepy from last night
we had a good time last night yeah it
was like it was it was good and well um
i mean we ended up not really drinking a
great deal because i didn't realize this
but
the bar they you know they moved
and they don't have their liquor license
anymore well they have a liquor license
it's just that they can't use it there
yeah it's not it's not they got to come
in and do an inspection and build a
bunch of [ __ ] you know
and uh
until they build it has to be like
certain
there has to be like certain like
storage rooms and there has to be
drainage and fountains and the floor has
to be just right before they can
actually use a liquor license in the
place
it's like a zoning type thing
or food service standards yeah yeah it
has to be that's what it is it has to be
brought up to code yeah because the
liquor licenses in orlando are like
super expensive yeah he's got one it's
just he's got to bring it up to code
so i mean they just had like they had
beer and they had like white claw and
[ __ ] like that yeah and they had
pre-mixed drinks yeah they had like a
little like a little tank array like gin
and tonic i think they couldn't have
anything over five percent alcohol or 10
or something like that whatever it was
so you know i had like a couple of
yanglings and one of those tanqueray
things and yeah i got i got one drink it
was like it was absolute vodka
but it also had lime and cucumber yeah
and i gave him some and he was like
that's [ __ ] horrible yeah i thought
it was horrible at first too but it
actually kind of grew on me
it was it was weird because it was like
the cucumber gave it like a weird like
kind of savory thing to it which i
wasn't expecting
but drinking that it i was kind of like
oh i wonder if they have like bloody
marys in a can because that'd be all
about that but i don't think they did i
had the mojito i hate it was good i was
thinking about getting that but i never
did and then like after that i was just
kind of like man i just wanted water
bacardi mojito
yes they got them like all in cans so
but what a lot of people i guess you
know it's been open for a while this is
like the first time that we went
but
a lot of people already knew that so
they just had like booze out in their
car like in the parking lot so they
would just like go outside and like
drink in the parking lot you know what i
mean
uh zach said i tried to scotch and toad
at the gay bar last week and my god it
almost made me puke i don't think i've i
don't think i've ever had a scotch and
soda have i not supposed to put soda and
scotch
that's a pretty that's a pretty common
drink though and whiskey scout's
supposed to drink that on the rocks
i've had a whiskey in soda and i wasn't
a fan i do like whiskey but i usually
like it mixed with like coke or
or if it's like a real nice
i kind of like that apple flavored
whiskey jack daniels had one for a while
and whatever the hell that other
uh what the [ __ ] is that other whiskey
called
i don't remember but they
they well they have no i mean like the
other brand oh i don't know they had
like an apple one and i remember liking
that a lot
and i just would drink that one like by
itself i had some for loco
yeah but um yeah so the cool thing about
it was that i was kind of stressing
because
you know i i bar barbarella was like my
favorite place and it was like downtown
and i knew that they had moved and i was
kind of like man they're way the [ __ ]
out on john young parkway and i was
thinking to myself god damn it that's so
far that's going to take us like an hour
to [ __ ] get there but then when i
google mapped it
it was like not far at all 30 miles yeah
it was 28 miles and i was just sitting
there going well [ __ ] that's not that
much farther and the thing is because
they've built like in the last few years
they built like some kind of toll
expressway type things like from from
here like from eustis to like kind of
bypassing downtown so it's like if you
take a toll road it took literally like
half an hour actually actually to get
back no it was less when it lasts more
like 25 minutes something like that to
get back i think we got back in 17
minutes right i was going 80.
yeah maybe no no no you when you asked
me okay how much farther is at home i
said 17 minutes but we were already over
there about five minutes prior yeah
we were already like into the journey by
that point it takes about half an hour
yeah but to be fair that's the same
amount of time it takes to drive to
mannequins and it's close yeah and
mannequins is closer but that's because
that's like stop and go traffic you
can't really you know what i mean so it
takes like the same yeah so it takes
like the same amount of time and this
one was like way better because it's
toll roads yeah nobody else on the road
and there's like hardly anybody else on
there i was like woohoo this is [ __ ]
awesome yeah because i was like i don't
know i guess i was thinking about it in
terms of i4 because i4
i just never want to drive on there ever
because that road is like a [ __ ] wide
awake nightmare you arrive down there
[ __ ] obt orange blossom trail where
all the [ __ ] strip clubs are in the
hooker hotels yeah yeah didn't see any
hookers though no we didn't see any
hookers i didn't really see i bought one
[Laughter]
well i kind of like it's kind of weird
like the location where they moved it
they basically moved it to like an
industrial park yeah like so it's like
where it's like a warehouse district
yeah it looks nice in there though it's
all [ __ ] black walls and i think it
used to be like a sports center like a
badminton
center or something like that uh that's
what it used to be so it's like this big
cavernous space
and the cool thing about it is that
one um there's parking like tons of
parking like right in front so you can
literally like walk outside and like sit
in your car and go you know smoke or
drink in your car or whatever no normies
in that [ __ ] and yeah and you
don't get any walk-ins because like i
said i bar used to be
right on the corner of like the main
drag
of downtown orlando so it's like you got
people just like wandering in off the
street
and some of them were really obnoxious
but where they are now you have to
specifically go to that place it's not
there's no other clubs around there's no
other nothing it's like in the middle of
just like a bunch of closed
warehouses like an industrial park so
you have to go there on purpose yep it
was straight up [ __ ] goth everybody
decked out
yeah a lot of people yeah a lot of
people came because it's the first
memento mori since i mean barbarella has
been opened at the new place for like a
month now i think so they've been doing
like saturday nights and stuff but this
is the first memento that they've done
there and so everybody was gonna come
out so holy [ __ ] we saw people that i
haven't seen in years for christ's sake
everybody showed up evan from ludovico
technique was there i hadn't seen him
for years
yeah [ __ ] susan was there too did you
see who was there yeah did you see her i
didn't notice that susan frame yeah i
didn't see her yeah i saw her across the
dance floor a lot of people had my blue
wig on so a lot of people like kept
walking past and being like oh it's you
you know what i mean i didn't even
notice susan was there yeah she was
there i saw her they weren't they
weren't fighting were they
not that i saw evan was like [ __ ]
dude you're the only person who's come
up and said hi to me the only one who
remembers me
that's really weird nobody remembers
evan he said well i mean he didn't come
every time but he usually like um you
know he was usually there like most of
the time yeah
zack says i like screwdrivers and wine
most other alcoholic drinks are either
too sweet or too bitter and i ain't
having it yeah i mean screwdrivers are
my favorite
uh that's usually what i get but i don't
mind like a jack and coke every now and
then or every now and then i'll have a
gin and tonic although like i said
i like one or two of those but i can't
really drink more than two of those
because they're way too tart and acidic
and they will make me like throw up um
but i like them every now and then
because they're kind of like refreshing
but yeah i mean i kind of like
we'll see how it goes i mean we need to
like try out now it's like he's now that
i know it's easy to get to
i definitely want to see like what the
saturdays are like like the 80s night
yeah and we'll check it out then but
danny says that [ __ ] a half hour
that's too far to drive if you've been
drinking and driving i said what country
you live in
what the [ __ ] you talking about well the
thing about it is like the roads i was
just so happy that the toll road i was
like i was like look dude i was like the
toll road goes almost right to it yeah
it's like you basically you take the
toll road like all the way to orange
blossom trail and then you get off and
it's like another three miles and then
it's like right there there were times
where we came back from the castle and
[ __ ]
yeah remember that time we came back and
had what's her name driving
that cr
that
remember that girl yeah what was her
name [ __ ] um one that moved off to
[ __ ] yeah why [ __ ] was her name she
moved to australia australia yeah
goddamn it was around i was [ __ ]
passing out in the back seat yeah you're
swerving all over the [ __ ] road and i
had to reach over there and grab the
[ __ ] wheel so drive straight remember
that
no what happened was there was all kinds
of [ __ ] that happened that night what
happened was yeah she said she was fine
and she was like well because we were
gonna take her to our house she could
sleep over and then she was gonna um
yeah back to her house yeah and so she
bought us some tacos in appreciation and
she's like i can drive i'm fine and i'm
like are you sure and she's like yeah
and because tom was like [ __ ] plat he
was out of it he was sleeping in the
backyard you were asleep yeah so i was
in the passenger seat she was driving
and then she just starts like weaving
like all of it i mean there wasn't
hardly anybody on the road it was like
four in the morning i think there was
like nobody around and she was like
weaving all over and at that point i was
just kind of like i was like immediately
sober and i was like hey why don't you
um pull over at that restaurant you
started drinking i'll drive yeah so i
drove i knew something was gonna go bad
i knew something was gonna go
yeah we're going to tampa that was over
an hour i mean tampa is far far yeah
tampa's far we were um
at the beginning part of the trip i was
in the back seat i was going i ain't
going to make it i'm getting ready to
pass out and as i was passing out i
looked up in the road ahead of us and
there was a car stopped in the in the
freeway stop dead stop
and she passed it at 85 miles an hour
right next to it like she didn't even
see it
and i said hey that was did you see that
card yeah what was that and i said
yeah what was that i was just like
whatever yeah
there was a car stopped in the middle of
the road why was it stopped and i said
you almost hit it and it goes no she
would no i didn't say yeah you cleared
it by about six inches
or the mirror is probably by six inches
that was [ __ ] that was some wild [ __ ]
there man and i said well [ __ ] this i'm
going to sleep
i'm going to die i'll die of my sleep
yeah wake me up when we die i mean after
that happen
i'm actually proud of myself because i
was like surprisingly calm
because like i said she was driving
crazy and that served me up real quick
and i was and i didn't yell at her
no what was her name what was her name i
didn't i've seen her in a long time yeah
i haven't seen her again she's a big
pretty [ __ ] about six foot one remember
yeah she's yeah and she was really
really tall and she was a beyond genius
she was immense she was part of that
menses yeah yeah memphis
she was a uh
a physicist yeah you just do that's
right yeah yeah yeah she could just do
advanced physics and [ __ ]
yeah i forgot her name though i did too
like i can see her face what's her
[ __ ] name i haven't seen her in like
years like i said she moved to australia
as far as i knew joshua was there she
was kind of like this uh
um good looking
real tall
goth
girl who was a genius or beyond genius a
physicist
and was into fetish stuff and was like
she was like in the throuple with the
bondage couple yeah the lawyer that's
right yeah for a while yeah that's right
she went there with them yeah she and
they would like make porn and stuff and
she was like
with all their equipment yeah their
garage
yeah they had all the [ __ ] set up yeah
garage and then uh she got it on with
little swell
that's right oh my god i forgot about
that in the car
wow yeah and i said how was it he goes
man it was awesome man she's tall though
because little swell is about five foot
four she's about six
one that's what i was that's why i was
like wow yeah big boobs and [ __ ] [ __ ]
good body i haven't seen her a long time
though for all i know she's [ __ ]
being waited or something but back in
those days that was how long ago
15 years
no it wasn't that long ago about 10 more
like yeah more like nine years
yeah but like i yeah she moved away and
we haven't like yeah a long time ago
little swell was quite impressed
[Laughter]
it's like i don't know if i can take
that man
[Laughter]
i don't know man chicken he's just he's
not exactly cars man it's not cool yeah
i i broke a gear shift in one yeah it
wasn't my car
that's that's the era of the little car
so i don't know how [ __ ] yeah i don't
remember what kind of car was that i
thought i broke the gear shifter
it was it was a little maybe a little
nissan or it's not like what it was it
was like a little burgundy car that's
all i remember
hugo said in cuba they make mojitos with
96 alcohol
yeah i mean you know the ones we drank
last night those are those ones i didn't
even know they i i mean i know about
like white claw and all that kind of
[ __ ] because i know that's like a big
huge thing now like all those kind of
like low alcohol
things that come in cans but i didn't
realize they had like a little gin and
tonic and little blah blah because i
don't usually drink that kind of stuff
but you know that's what they had
until they get their liquor license and
i was just like that's fine well because
i didn't really know like i said we've
never been there and i was just kind of
like i want to make sure that i don't
get too [ __ ] up in case i need to do
the gps like to get back because i don't
know where it is and everything like
that so i wasn't planning on drinking
all that much anyway so when they got
there and tiff was like
we only have beer in these things and i
was just kind of like whatever whatever
yeah i mean it was still fun dude said
that he took the mensa test and reader's
dad just no she was a real mensa
she was a real man
she was like from she was like from a
big university when she from like
stanford or some [ __ ] like that or
notredom or something yeah i can't
remember yeah it was it was definitely
like i think it was ivy league it was
like an ivy league school
yeah she's cool as hell though i like
yeah and you would never know that by
looking at her
and
i kind of feel like that's true about a
lot of
maybe i i guess the stereotype isn't
around as much as it used to be but it's
like really funny because sometimes you
would think that like you see these
people with you know big [ __ ] spiky
hair and like pierced lips and [ __ ] like
that and you think oh they're just bums
or whatever and i was like no that guy's
a veterinarian and that guy this she's a
lawyer and right that's she's a
pharmacist and all this other kind of
[ __ ] like they have real jobs
a lot of veterans like you know evan the
guy i was talking to he's kind of the
brains behind a band called ludovico
technique which is real good yeah
they're a good band they're real good
bad they're bigger now than they ever
were
um if you looked at evan evan's in good
shape he's about my size [ __ ] he's
he's now 41.42 and anyway
he was a [ __ ] uh fighter pilot f-16
fighter pilot you wouldn't know but
though you know he just looks like a
band dude but he [ __ ] know everything
about [ __ ] avionics and [ __ ]
aviation and
it's just you know you can't really
judge a book by its cover yeah
absolutely not especially not in that
scene you don't know anything about
you can't you can't tell anything about
the person like other than they like
goth [ __ ] you don't know anything about
their past or anything like that which
is cool i think that's cool
uh thank you zack i just thought that a
show about frank lloyd wright would be
awesome i actually wanted to do a show
about the um that massacre like at that
house that he built because
um i have a book about that
which maybe you said that to me did you
send that to me i kind of feel like but
uh he said on that note do you guys have
a favorite building architecture-wise
oh interesting that's an interesting
question i don't know i'm really into
i don't know if i really like modern
buildings all that much i'm really into
like gothic
architecture like gothic cathedrals and
stuff and i really like
kind of like the 1920s like art deco
kind of era i like that kind of stuff
other than that not so much i'm not
really into kind of like the modernist
or brutalist or whatever the [ __ ] i
don't
it's just i i like real ornate like
baroque looking stuff generally
and let me see
tammy said she figured out that remember
she said she wanted uh
ideas about what to name the puppy she
named it alfie yeah oh
my sister just got a new puppy as well i
don't remember what she named him though
she just told me
she's coming down in october she's doing
another vacation at disney
so
i was like because she's like pretty
much spending the whole thing she likes
to
kind of like she does that whole package
which is however many like 1500 or
whatever it is and you stay there in the
disney hotels and then like you get
passes to all the parks and you have all
the dinner reservations and [ __ ] like
that so she's doing that
um
and i was kind of like well obviously i
can't afford to like go to the park and
hang out with you but she's like oh well
one day we're gonna do disney springs
which i think is free so i might go and
see her then but we'll see
brad jones says smoke weed y'all uh nah
i don't
i i smoked it a couple times but it's
not really i don't know maybe i just
didn't get good [ __ ] but
oh that's right we were supposed to
re-review conan
oh yeah that's right yeah
all three of them all three including
jason momoa okay
well the thing about it okay so
obviously we were out last night so we
didn't see a movie that's why we're
doing a sidetrack today plus it's kind
of a holiday so i figured out what the
[ __ ]
now tonight we were initially going to
watch godfather 2
and review that tomorrow but then tom
was like holy crap that's probably like
three hours long too and i don't know if
i could stay awake through that whole
thing and i was like yeah probably i
can't either so what we'll probably do
tonight is like just pick a movie
that either we haven't reviewed before
or
you know that we've seen and is not that
it's not that strenuous like to watch um
or one that we
reviewed but like a long time ago that
has to be redone that we should redo
because like
i mean yeah eventually we need to redo
[ __ ] um
uh uh one of our most popular ones which
was uh
uh
[ __ ]
what's the one where they're living in a
damn city logan's vogue is run yeah we
should redo logan's run because the the
video the audio quality isn't very good
on that one a lot of the early ones that
we did like i particularly i was
thinking about like legend of hell house
and stuff like that i wouldn't mind like
redoing those right
just because and those are like movies
that i'm really into right so maybe we
can do conan or we can do a [ __ ] that
vincent price one uh about the vampires
the uh i am legend maybe do something
like that last man on earth last man on
earth yeah
that might be a good one to do i think
that might be on to be for free i have
to look it up i'll look and see if it's
not then we'll find something else for
free okay
yeah danny rowling says jenny agatha was
hot as [ __ ] logan's run yeah i mean
she was hot as [ __ ] in general she was
also hot as [ __ ] american werewolf in
london part of it was that dress though
it was way up to the side and everything
it looked really good but yeah you need
to have something like that for the club
with a little slippers yeah not green
though i don't know no like a goth
version of that something slit way up
the side yeah that'd look good yeah
zach says you should get your sister on
the show wonder she'd want to be on the
show like i said i don't think she's
gonna have time to come over here
because we're kind of far away but that
would be kind of cool to she lives in
atlanta by the way so that's why
she's moved all over i mean she lived in
seattle she lived in
uh
providence did she live in providence or
did she just get i don't remember she
lived in
pennsylvania i think for a while and
then she lived in denver for a really
long time because i visited her out
there a couple times that was beautiful
rick shaw says i just watched x i liked
it is it cheap to rent yet because i
looked the other day because i think it
was oscar has been like nagging me to
watch it and i do want to watch it i'm
just i'm teasing you about saying
nagging but
um
but last time i looked like a few days
ago it was still 20 bucks and i was just
kind of like
i can't really afford like 20 bucks to
watch it but when it comes down to maybe
like six bucks maybe then i'll watch it
because i do want to see it it seems
like everybody's like talking about how
good hugo is saying yeah logan's running
maybe some of the best shows of the tv
series talking about the tv series
logan's run yeah because we talked about
that yeah i think we did it we did uh
just a comprehensive review on the
series we did just a series yeah we did
i think he's asking for shows on the
series that would be a long that would
take a long time yeah but um we need
something we need something tonight
that's like that's like low stress yeah
john smith says never seen the tv show
where is it available i'm not sure yeah
we have it like on dvd i didn't even
know that there was a tv show until
recently like we kind of like discovered
well it's just kind of like the dead
zone i didn't even know there was a tv
series of the dead zone yeah and that's
and that's actually really good too yeah
the tv the tv series is good a lot of
the same writers from original star trek
um
production quality is a little bit
better than original star trek
a lot of stuff from that
got borrowed
and ended up in star trek the next
generation
yeah star trek next generation i would
say there's a a character in there they
meet named ram
and ram ends up being their sidekick and
it's data
essentially essentially it's data it's
like a proto data yeah it's real close
to data and the dude that plays him is
the guy who played copper from the thing
you know the guy who's i did not go near
that blood you know that that guy that
guy he he plays ram and it ram is
actually the most uh is actually the
most
uh there's the best character he's
easily the best easily he saves [ __ ]
logan and jessica [ __ ] repeatedly
he's always saving them and yeah because
their dumb houses are always getting
into trouble
he explains [ __ ] to him because he's
ancient he's been around for centuries
he was made like a long time ago
so he knows what it is when he finds old
stuff
um the series is good i don't think you
you can stream it i think you have to
buy it
i mean as far as i know you can do like
logan's run tv series when what year was
it 1970 77 77 it was only like a year or
two after the movie came out yeah it was
good it's just that star wars came out
and blew everything out of the water and
in
all interest in um logan's run as a
movie vanished and they they just killed
the series
you know uh i think it's once one season
wasn't it one i think it was just one
season because i think that's like 12 or
13 episodes yeah and it's worth watching
it's like watching old star trek yeah
it's like it's pretty good
the writing is mostly good some of it's
pretty derivative you know what i mean
like they're they'll rehash [ __ ]
classic literature like most dangerous
game you know somebody's hunting
somebody kind of feel like every series
has to have a most dangerous game type
episode you might rehash a [ __ ] old
classic like noah's ark or something you
know or [ __ ] uh aliens being trapped
by bad people on holdcat
they run into aliens
uh they run into all kinds of [ __ ]
[ __ ] um
places that are old love motels that are
damn staffed by [ __ ] robots and they
don't you don't find out till later
they're all [ __ ] robots and
it's just
it's good it's just kind of fun you know
um
they got a
jessica's played by a kind of a fair
fawcett knockoff you know
bargain basement fairfax that's mean
well
that heather menzies that's heather
she's cute and she's a good actress but
she has the the patented
fair faucet haircut and they got her in
there to look
as close close to pharah faucet as they
can so instead of having some chick that
looked like jenny atticator they got a
chick that looked like fair faucet
because in the united states the draw to
logan's run was farrah fawcett that's
why people were going to go see it and
she has a five-minute party even yeah
she was in like one scene like two
scenes
[Laughter]
yeah that's really funny yeah
and in fact until you mentioned that i
had totally forgotten that pharah foster
was even in yeah logan's run the movie
and i was like oh yeah that's right she
had like two lines i was like in third
or fourth grade when he came out
and all the little boys were just going
oh farrah's in it fair fawcett's in it
they're going on about fair fawcett and
half of them boys had the vera fair
faucet posters and [ __ ] mostly their
older brothers had it but they you know
they thought fair foster was the [ __ ]
you know greatest thing ever
you know [ __ ] charlie's angels and
[ __ ]
yeah yeah those other those other
charlie's angels must have been like
[ __ ] yeah jacqueline smith
uh
jaclyn smith and [ __ ] what was that
oh damn uh i had i just had it and then
it slipped out of my brain
yeah and recently they tried to [ __ ]
recreate that and come up with movies of
charlie's angels recently and boy that
[ __ ] flops every time that only worked
in that era
because television there were only
four channels and it was easy to
dominate
culture just through four channels you
know well everybody was seeing the same
[ __ ] yeah you're kind of forced to watch
it's captive audience they can channel
you down through there and they could
make something as pedestrian as
charlie's angels a [ __ ] sensation
you can't do that now there's too many
other things to choose from
[ __ ] man they even had like knockoff
charlie's angels movies because mst did
one called angel's revenge which is
terrible terrible but
super fun though yeah i mean if the the
mst episode was good
dj maniac said was it cheryl ladd cheryl
i think it was cheryl well now wait a
minute wasn't there originally i think
yeah but wasn't there like three of them
and then there was like another one like
didn't one of them get fired or they
replaced someone and then they replaced
one of them i think they replaced pharah
fawcett eventually didn't they
i don't know i didn't really watch that
show but you know what's really weird
is that i had the dolls of them yeah
like the three little dolls that had
their little um
you know their little jumpsuits like one
of them had a red jumpsuit and one was
white and one was yellow but
i'm like who gave those to me i don't
think i would have bought those because
i didn't really watch the show i think
that charlie's angel's lunch box too
american television at that time was a
[ __ ] trip i can remember my dad
jacked he was [ __ ] jacked that
[ __ ] a new [ __ ] program was coming
out he'd been waiting for it cause man i
can't wait i'm gonna watch that when
that comes
i do the voice of my dad's voice man
that looks good i'm gonna watch that
when that comes i'm watching that and it
was sex million dollar man
all right
my dad loves six million dollar man
he liked it for a while i think when he
got to bionic bigfoot he's like oh hell
no
bionic bigfoot i ain't watching nobody
he's like even for the 70s yeah
but i liked it
and then uh you know i had that [ __ ]
intro and [ __ ] it was almost kind of
like more proto-industrial
he's a man barely alive
we can rebuild
[Laughter]
you know
better stronger faster oh [ __ ] he's on
roads [ __ ] potential and then they
came out with looking bionic woman yeah
which i actually liked bionic woman i
like the bonnet woman too i would have
watched bionic cat
cat
bionic pookie yeah
yeah can you imagine like no oh now i'm
gonna like take some video of pookie
like doing some crazy [ __ ] and i'm gonna
put like six million dollars
that'd be super fun yeah i also was
i was gone i was [ __ ] getting way
into wonder woman and i really wasn't
sure why but that was the boobs that
[ __ ] those boobs and legs well done
but when you're [ __ ] i like wonder
woman when you're seven or eight you're
not really quite sure why you're just
like why am i so fascinated
there's like this bondage fantasy her
running around with that damn [ __ ]
whip cord tying people up with that with
me linda carter she had that black hair
blue eyes and she with that little
[ __ ] tiara around her head you know
she's a lesbian she's from the height of
lesbos oh yeah
[Laughter]
let it be known who's in charge that's
right step on his testicles sit on that
[ __ ]
punish him
bounce it bounce it
right on his face
john smith says i saw jenny agatha in
walkabout at a young age and made me
realize girls might be something worth
paying attention to i never saw that one
i saw it a long time ago being really
good um danny rowling says tom should
check out the crustal 1980 film used
cars it's pretty funny yeah i think uh i
think i've seen it but i probably saw it
like when i was a kid i think i've seen
it yeah okay we'll have to look for that
one as well
uh let me see what looking somebody sent
me a movie uh the head crustle and it
was called uh the
the deadly tower where he plays [ __ ]
charles charles whitman yeah he's good
in that he's really good in that yeah
uh caitlin higgins have you guys
reviewed any of the stargate movies i
don't think we have we haven't even done
this
yeah we haven't even done the original
stargate have we yeah we can do it i can
i can i should probably buy it that's a
crustal movie not one of my favorites
but
yeah i haven't seen it in a long time
but i remember liking it
it had good elements mixed with cheese
elements but a lot of movies from that
era did
you know i mean it was totally uneven it
would be kind of adventurous and serious
and then there'd be like goofy gags and
then it would kind of go back to being
they were
our my dad loved the tv series he said
the tv series blew the
blue the uh
the movie out of the water
i've heard a lot of people really liked
that tv yeah you know
i don't think i ever watched it though
my dad loved it
i liked [ __ ] one it was called
farscape i think it was called farce oh
yeah yeah that was on the side that was
on the sci-fi sci-fi channel i remember
that they had the blue chick yeah they
had the earth guy and then they had the
sexy [ __ ] space cop chick the
peacekeeper and they were in that [ __ ]
yeah and they were in that ship i
couldn't i wasn't able to see every
episode i would just catch it when i
could
yeah
and then they had the uh
the ship was alive
and the the computer system slash
captain was kind of like in a chair he
was growing out of it he was part of the
ship it was a really good series i
thought it was just like a
unique take on the space adventure
you know
i thought it was a good idea i don't
know if i ever saw it i just always
remember
when because mst was on the sci-fi
channel about the same time that
farscape was on so i remember always
seeing like the previews for it and like
commercials and stuff but i don't know
if i ever like watched an episode i
might have because i think a guy that i
worked with used to tape it sometimes
farscape would be worth buying i
wouldn't mind having that another one
that i want to buy but it's [ __ ]
expensive
it's called dark angel
and the writer producer was a guy who
did uh [ __ ]
terminator one and all the other one was
james cameron
he did it it had a young
alba and jessica alba's in it
and she plays like a genetically
engineered experimental kind of like
super soldier it's kind of like a lita
battle angel is what it is i think it's
a ripoff of elita battle angel but she
isn't
she isn't a robot she's a
genetically engineered
human kind of like a replicant
and i got to see like
six or seven episodes i liked it but i
wasn't able to finish it i don't
remember what happened just life took
over had to go somewhere
and never was never able to get back
into it and
i don't know what happened to that
series
so i went back on
i went back in the internet try to see
if i could buy it they wanted a lot of
money for it like 100 something dollars
it must be pretty rare yeah well if they
want 170 maybe that maybe it was like a
lot of episodes i think it was only two
or two seasons
oh okay well yeah i think it was a
limited edition tight limit they didn't
print that many of them and you can't i
don't know if you guys have ever seen it
it's good it was it was at least what i
saw first maybe 10 episodes
and i was wondering what the hell was
going to happen they didn't tell you
much about her she just and she didn't
know what she could do
she was finding out what she could do as
as it would go on and it was you know a
lot of wire work there was no cg it was
all practical effects it was good yeah
what year was that was that 90s um
just late 90s just turned in 2000 oh
okay i think might have been like 96 96
98 no maybe like 2 000.
might have been 2000 when that came out
i liked it
jessica was probably about
18 or 19
and she was unknown
yeah
i kind of remember hearing about it at
the time but
i don't think i ever saw it she had a
[ __ ]
black ninja 600 ninja motorcycle and
wear leather motorcycle suits could
shoot guns could fight with her hands
she could see in the dark
she could jump really far
she could climb up walls
um
that was i could
that's about what i think she could do
she could compute things real fast in
her head she didn't know how she was
doing it she could just do it
glenn says rewatched ghosts of the civil
dead yeah that's one with nick cave
isn't it yeah yeah knight rider for mad
max is in it and nick cave is in it good
old movie very violent i remember seeing
that like a long time ago because i was
because i love nick cape so i've seen
like everything that he was in kate
jackson that was the other one that's
who i was thinking of
maybe so maybe cheryl ladd like replaced
farrah fawcett later but yeah kate
jackson was who i was thinking of on
charlie's angels
um john smith said i used to love buck
rogers in the 25th century i used to
like that too like i watched that when i
was a kid
uh
camp guy charlie's angels was it for me
at least a couple of nipple shirts every
episode
danny rowling says the 1974 english
great zombie film let sleeping corpses
lie aka living dead at the manchester
morgue starring ray lovelock would make
a good tuesday movie review instead of
godfather 2. that's actually a really
good movie i saw it probably about 10
years ago and i remember like really
liking it i thought i used to have it on
dvd but i don't think i do if i do i
have lost it at some point
um danny rowling says kressel and
stargate looked his best in my opinion
no homo yeah
that was dark angel
and it was um
hold on yeah james camp james cameron's
dark angel
trying to get folks that was a good
series
john smith said farscape was an amazing
underrated show and ian england says lol
tom i'm re-watching farscape now got it
on got it on dvd yeah how much did you
pay
people used to make fun of farscape
because it had a lot of puppets in it
due to being made by the henson
corporation see i used to like i like
that though
what's wrong with what's wrong with
gymnasts and puppets okay look
you can get the complete series on
amazon new for 179 that's [ __ ]
first and second season
um you can get dark angel season one six
discs used for twenty dollars on ebay
okay well there you go yeah
um yeah twenty dollars let's see if the
but look it's 170 for the complete one
goddamn yeah but like i said that's how
much you're gonna change so hard to find
evidently
i mean okay second season complete is
23. that's not as bad as it was yeah
it's just maybe when i looked there
weren't any used ones
thank you camp guy
it says happy memorial day thank you
happy memorial day to you as well
you know what i was looking at earlier
for some reason i can't afford to buy it
but i kind of wanted to get the whole
series of
alfred hitchcock presents
because i used to love that [ __ ] i
love all those horror anthology shows
like night gallery and all that kind of
stuff now night gallery i think you can
watch that on hulu for free or at least
you used to be able to
um but alfred hitchcock presents and the
alfred hitchcock hour i used to really
really like those like from the 50s and
60s and i was looking earlier they have
a big box set with the whole complete
series but i think it's like 187 or
something i was just
but it was a lot of episodes they did a
lot of episodes
well okay fair enough dude somebody's
trip i like blair in some [ __ ] music
yeah what are they doing they're [ __ ]
throwing a damn country party
in our driveway yeah it sounds like it's
in our driveway yeah it's probably next
yeah
can you guys hear that that's really
that that's really loud
holy [ __ ]
let me see what this dudes up what is he
doing look out the window holy crap
it's like what are you doing out there
okay it's gone did you hear that poop i
told him to get the [ __ ] out
[ __ ] down they're going what the [ __ ]
is that she's like who are those people
making that noise it's funny
he tom brought like he carried pookie in
here this morning apparently she was uh
what'd you say she did like she ran in
the room and
kind of like rolled over like sticking
her belly out no she attacked and then
as soon as i reached down she [ __ ]
throws herself on the ground trying to
surrender like don't do it and i [ __ ]
like it
and then i put a stop and she's like
that's it i thought it was i thought
yeah
trying to get me
it's bad
john smith says i can hear it in
scotland yeah
[ __ ] could hear you in scotland
yeah what the [ __ ] i gotta [ __ ] see
where this is coming from hold on
i'm gonna make this [ __ ] pay later
let's see where it's coming from
thank you zack by the way they announced
season four of true detective ooh it's
set in alaska and jody foster is gonna
be the main character ooh that's gonna
be [ __ ] good
uh
let's see dj maynack says uh alfred
hitchcock presents had newer episodes in
the 80s yeah that's right i remember
those um followed by ray bradbury
theater which i own on dvd yeah that's
right
man i loved all those horror anthologies
i noticed that toby had
thriller
that show
who did you see who it is right in front
of the house next to us
that's the neighbor he's got his truck
out there
and another guy's got his truck out
there
and they pulled the mud truck from the
back and they got that in front of the
house
and they blame he's letting him play the
radio because he's sitting there trying
to sell the mud truck
mud truck sail in progress
my truck's sailing from yeah if you guys
know what a mud truck is
for you
foreigners
just [ __ ] go on youtube and go
florida
mud truck
you know uh event and just search it
you'll see
you get a truck
it's not even not the new ones are not
even normal sized trucks they're these
little bitty trucks it almost looks like
an electric truck there's no
it's the size of a [ __ ] compact car
all right it's little
and it doesn't have any doors or
anything it's just kind of like a roll
cage with a body on it it looks like a
it looks like a damn
a gator or one of those little
little utility vehicles that you ride
around in your uh
farm on not a real car or a truck it's
like a something you haul
the bale of hay to the [ __ ] barn with
to feed the horses all right it doesn't
have any it might have a front
windshield but it doesn't have any glass
sides and
it may not even have doors on it and it
might have just a bed in the back
it's the size of a [ __ ]
volkswagen bug
but then underneath it it's got a
suspension that's about 10 feet tall
maybe 12 feet tall
and they're splayed out
and the tires on them aren't very big
they're not like a monster truck tires
it's just like
the tires are maybe the size of the back
wheels of a tractor
okay
and uh they don't ask me why okay this
is a redneck thing they're not thinking
sensibly but then you take that well par
for the course
[Laughter]
i'm not sure they're street legal but
that wouldn't stop them they'd drive
that [ __ ] on the street
around in this area it's not going to go
very far in it
you take that and you drive it through
these big old [ __ ] mud pits filled
with [ __ ] mud and water
and blasting the stereo
with a half nude slightly overweight
booty chick in the back two or three of
them
that's what you can see the mud truck
events is
and there'd be whole parades of them
going through the same mud
i don't really know and the point of
that is
it's a part they're drinking too it's
par it's partying
in these vehicles
designed to go through big mud puddles
and throw mud everywhere
[Laughter]
if i had if it has to be explained you
wouldn't understand it i don't
understand it so i can't explain it
it's it's a redneck thing tom wouldn't
understand yeah what are they saying
john smith says one of my most cherished
possessions as a kid was my alfred
hitchcock solve them yourself mysteries
book i remember that i think i might
have had that as well i really liked all
of those um
alfred hitchcock presents like those
anthology books like with all the short
stories in them i had a bunch of those
and i read a bunch of those and i really
liked if you guys remember the three
investigators series it was kind of like
hardy boys but cooler it was like three
kids that like solved mysteries i think
most of them were written in the 60s but
there were like 40 something of them and
i read all of those too when i was a kid
uh hugo says i love mud trucks yeah and
rick says i've just ordered myself the
floridian butcher yeah
the girls also might be for sale you
have to [ __ ] check
check with your local distributor
your local girl distributor yeah here
that's the k that could be taken wrong
just
just in case you don't believe me this
is it that's what we're talking about
well those ones aren't overweight there
you go no
all right that's just a regular truck
my regular mud truck
like i said if i have to explain it you
wouldn't understand they're like let's
turn this truck over
turn it on over get on the other side
and just push
yeah put the girl on that side that'll
flatten her out son
yeah that'll flatten her out some yeah
do they even know she's over there
though
she just goes over and goes let me help
out i'll pull
i'll pull
you know with my breath yeah yeah pull
it put one here and one there and it'll
float through
there you go see
yeah
all right now
and they're listening to rap
they listen to rap music and its country
music has been converted to rap
country music now sounds like rat
and sometimes firearms are involved
alcohol's involved and there's aks in
there and ar-15s and they shoot too
during this
i mean maybe not in that area but
there's there's gunfire and [ __ ]
happening
it's it's a trip
that's what they like to do
it's an event and i don't think there's
a score or anything
yeah
like oh we're [ __ ] now
put her in reverse it'll be all right
[Laughter]
you got staff
he's going mom back come on back
straight out the wheel that's what he
said
oh you [ __ ] now pretty much yeah
let's fast forward a little bit
that's my truck transportation system
yeah okay that's one it's like a moving
barge with wheels
okay that's the one that's like what
they're selling like that
that's the kind they're selling next
door
that that type well i wish somebody's
gonna buy it they'd hurry up yeah it's
got a badass stereo in it
it's a mud buggy except it's about 10
feet tall it's like that but it's jacked
up about 10 feet
okay so
uh rickshaw says what about the outer
limits yeah that was good too all right
so you know what i haven't seen all of
the i've seen all of the twilight zones
but i don't think i've seen all of the
outer limits maybe that's another thing
that i need to like go back and watch
danny rowling says the 1989 canadian
psychological thriller hider in the
house starring gary busey and mimi
rogers would make for a great movie
review tomorrow probably my favorite
psychological thriller and scary as [ __ ]
you know what i've heard of that but i
don't think
that i've ever seen it maybe i should
write that down can you give me that pen
over there somebody's saying the second
scene is bad the third one is okay what
are they talking about true detective
what do you say what are you asking for
yeah somebody's sending us the third
season the first one was good i like the
first one well zach just said the fourth
season is coming out is it right yeah
with and it's set in alaska so let me
put hydra in the house because i don't
think i've ever seen that
let me write it down and see if i can
find it
uh john smith i like the 90s outer
limits i didn't even know they redid
yeah yeah i guess i kind of remember
that i kind of remember that
let me see
rick shaw says holy crap i'm kind of
worried now what is he worried about i
don't know okay
he goes yeah they listen to moonshine
bandits all day you guys said that i
don't know who that is
it might be who it is they're listening
to
it's imagine a a country western band
that's rapping that it's not bad
but they consider that to be country and
to me i'm like that's not country that's
rap it's just whatever well the thing
about it is that i remember rock went
that way yeah well yeah rock went that
way and also i remember
country going more toward
mainstream like
pop or rock music like in the 90s you
have all that kind of so i just kind of
figured it just
you know it's trying to like get
mainstream appeal i guess so one one of
the ones that they're listening to all
the time i think is called monster truck
i think the name of the name of the band
this is a monster truck but nobody's
going to tell me how to live i hear that
one a lot at the biker bar
yeah that was good no one's gonna tell
me how to live yeah
they mean it i do what i want i do what
i want yeah they absolutely wait why am
i in jail now yeah
they don't care they're
they're kamikazes
yeah danny rowling says hyder in the
house film deserves a series in my
opinions yeah see i'm okay now i'm
intrigued i'm gonna have to watch that
slasher fred says one of these days you
should review the foreign version of the
vanishing oh yeah
that's a good movie i know they did they
did an american remake of it which i
think was okay but i think the foreign's
like way way better
um
yeah hugo said it's more like hip-hop
country yeah
i mean you know
it's not really my thing but whatever
i'm not really into rednecky [ __ ] and
i'm kind of
growing up in daytona beach i had that
all leashed out of me i was like no
thanks
to you not for me i can hang out in it
for limited times
it starts getting like uh real samey to
me and it started going like i feel like
i'm back in the army too much i don't
like on an army base
because the army bases are [ __ ] super
generic i would call it basis not a bad
army fort or an army cap real generic
and that you you'd hear that [ __ ] billy
ray cyrus and [ __ ] all with all times
you know
i think i would probably like to jump in
front of a bus
put up with that
for any length of time yeah korean over
it
the 506 up in korea camp grieves with
the one that was just constantly
starting to get to me that broke me when
it came to metallica
master of puppets in the black album
just [ __ ] wore me out because that
everybody just [ __ ] played that over
and over and over and the beginnings of
that damn
pearl jam i think it was her sound
garden it was one of the two it was one
of the ones i didn't really like dude
and um
then [ __ ] alice in chains came out
and they [ __ ] played that [ __ ] into
the ground and [ __ ] like turn that
[ __ ] out other dudes were getting sad
somebody had to have that [ __ ] [ __ ]
blast into [ __ ] alison chains alison
chang's [ __ ] troll was [ __ ] crazy
when that came out
they just could not refrain from that
[ __ ] man in the box and a [ __ ] what
was the other one i still get that
[ __ ] song stuck in my head sometimes
even though i haven't heard it for
probably years but every now and then
it'll pop in my head and i don't know a
lot of the words i just know a few of
the words here and there and it'll just
pop in my head like unbidden and then
i'm just like get out get out
man in the box and the rooster they
played it over and over again now it's
gonna get stuck in my head again god
damn it god damn it and [ __ ] there
were dudes that were [ __ ] losing it
and [ __ ] guys would say if i hear
[ __ ] the rooster one more time
whoever plays that [ __ ] i'm breaking
your [ __ ] jab box i'm breaking it and
they made it they [ __ ] throw the jam
boxes
or you're buying another one
pissing on the [ __ ] thing
kicking it and [ __ ] i mean you can't
really play got sick of that man can we
be laughing i mean do not play the
rooster
you know how many times and i think i've
told you this before but the house that
i used to live in in daytona
the guy that lived next door to me i
can't remember what his name was he was
the world's biggest leonard skinner fan
yeah and he had a cd that was like all
their hits yeah and he played that
[ __ ] cd at full
volume yeah
several multiple times a day yeah and he
would sing along and it would start like
early in the morning and back then when
i lived at that house i worked the night
shift so i didn't usually get home like
i worked at a newspaper i didn't usually
get home to like three in the morning so
i like to at least sleep until like nine
or ten in the morning like so i could
get some decent sleep no 7 a.m he's out
there with his [ __ ] hedge trimmer
blaring
leonard skinner yeah and singing at the
top of his [ __ ] voice
and i was just kind of like dude
i understand why some people murder
their neighbors yeah
big time i was like maybe i could poison
him i actually did like think about i
wonder if i could poison him without
getting caught
i don't know if any of you guys are
[ __ ] fans of dave chappelle but
there's real good [ __ ] episodes where
dave on the dave chappelle so
i spilled cold water myself on the dave
chappelle show
charlie murphy who is eddie murphy's
brother is on there telling stories
about what he and his brother used to do
around with rick james and [ __ ]
prince okay
and there's some of the best episodes or
stories are about rick james he said
they should have never gave you
almost a [ __ ] they should never
gave you [ __ ] money all right
that's
that was the way the army was they
should have never gave them
[ __ ] money because as soon as
they had money they bought those jab
boxes and they would [ __ ] play the
rooster and they'd play all that [ __ ]
and it was like
they're they're young guys you know
[ __ ]
late teens early 20s
first time away from home and
it's i guess it's okay to be loud you
know
when you're at the barracks and they'll
play that [ __ ] over and over again
because that's their only possession is
that [ __ ] jam box and those [ __ ]
cds some of them and you're like save up
and buy a car get the [ __ ] out of here
we call them barracks rats okay a lot of
them were sending their money back homes
or or spending it on so much booze that
they they never [ __ ] were able to get
out of the damn barracks
[ __ ] that i was buying motorcycles
getting the [ __ ] out of there okay
but um
that's what it is man they should have
never gave these [ __ ] money
they wear it in the ground and [ __ ] your
couch that too all right
so i'm gonna say i'm gonna say i'm gonna
say rick james there was an amount of
wisdom in rick james he knew what he was
talking about
i mean i never really understood
why
you
feel the need to like impose your noise
in general but like why you feel the
need to like impose your music on other
people i'm like is
like people that just drive around like
blaring the [ __ ] in their cars or like
just blared out of their windows they're
showing you that they got something
that's but i'm just like no one cares
though they don't care just annoying
everyone you're keeping me awake you're
making me want to kill you i'm not
really sure what you think you're
accomplishing like you know what i mean
i don't and people can listen to
whatever music they want but it's like i
don't why the [ __ ] do i want to hear
yeah it's just really obnoxious coming
here [ __ ] sad i tried to get out of
the barracks as much as i could on the
[ __ ] weekends man just [ __ ] run
off just crash at other people's houses
anything of going back to the barracks
because whatever barracks floor you were
on it was [ __ ] five different rooms
in that barracks all right all in a
[ __ ] war over who had the [ __ ] who
whose music should be heard
it's just a constant sonic war because
then they're all drunk i'm like do they
do they not know that headphones exist
i guess that's [ __ ] a sign of
weakness or something
[Laughter]
you got [ __ ] outs and chains blasting
out of one [ __ ] room you got [ __ ]
metallica blasted out of another one and
then you'd have [ __ ] some r b blasted
out of a [ __ ] another one and it is
[ __ ] ridiculous you know [ __ ]
sonic wars
that's that's and beer cans everywhere
beer cans everywhere because they're
young young guys yeah it's weekend and
they're just like it's like a frat house
on the weekend yeah that's just the
grossest yeah i mean i've been in like
so many apartments of like dudes and
they're like roommates and stuff because
i have brothers and you know my
friends boyfriends and [ __ ] like that
it's like you people like it's like you
guys are like disgusting yeah it's just
kind of like just they're disgusting as
soon as you walked in i was like what's
that smell
you know what i mean
it's just i don't know ass and unwashed
dishes and unwashed laundry and yeah old
beer cans that they couldn't be bothered
to throw away i'm like jesus christ what
the [ __ ] it's like you look looks like
orders
murder hornet says uh my cousin went to
a skinner concert she said there was a
guy behind her yelling leonard skinner
over and over and over
yeah i've seen that before too
yeah [ __ ] back there gonna want
to yell iron maiden all night and [ __ ]
[ __ ] let it yeah i'm just gonna turn
around like stab you right in the
eyeball okay
do you mind if i do that holy [ __ ]
that was i mean but littered skittered
neighbor that was like bad too but when
i lived in tampa
i worked at a print shop and the guy
that managed it or owned it i can't
remember he was like the world's biggest
jimmy buffett fan
and this young guy came to work there he
was like working the press he was like
18 or something and he was also super
into jimmy buffet which is probably why
he got hired and the two of them
would play again the same jimmy buffett
cd over and over and over and over and
then like while i worked there i didn't
work there very long because i said i'm
about to like shoot myself or someone
else if i have to put up with this
anymore and they actually went to see
jimmy buffett live and so then they were
like super jacked about it like every
day they would like talk about it they
would like relive it and i'm just kind
of like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i got so sick
of that cd yeah it was the same one they
played like the same one i don't it was
i don't know which one it was it was
like the greatest hits like so didn't
have like margaritaville which is pretty
much the only song that i know yeah but
i all i remember is it had a song called
math socks on it yeah and i was like oh
boy anti-intellectualism for the win
love it but yeah it was like super
annoying no need for me is saying that
when he was in they just used [ __ ]
walkman and portable cd players the
headphones yeah we had to we had that
yeah we hit that too because you
couldn't be loud all the time you know
uh there was other [ __ ] going on uh but
what i was talking about with all the
noise that was weekends
when yeah everybody was off duty
uh in the barracks it was became a frat
house and they were barbecuing and they
were drinking
and they were [ __ ]
playing football and [ __ ] out in front
they were doing all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
yeah just because it's just a bunch of
young guys they don't they can't go
anywhere everybody else is gone
you know guys that had cars and
most of the ncos would be home with
their families but you know you have cq
there doing patrols and the mps watching
you and [ __ ] but no during the weekends
it was just like a battle for home was
making the most [ __ ] noise because
if you were there on a weekend half a
time it always depends on what mission
cycle you were in but if there was
nothing going on it was just they knew
when when it was safe to party you
didn't want to be around there when
you're partying to just drive you
[ __ ] crazy oh yeah wow i know loud
yeah
it's nothing but just [ __ ] crazy ass
rednecks
and [ __ ] and drunk mexican guys and
[ __ ] dudes from the hood all
competing to who's going to be [ __ ]
loudest
yeah and they all love each other they
turn up the stereos
like probably all yell and go like
yeah exactly exactly
jumping out of three-story windows and
[ __ ] just that's how dumb they are it is
funny though
why do you think that that would
surprise me just
jumping out three like i said i'm from
daytona beach every year they had spring
break and it's like every year we'd have
at least one [ __ ] ham drunk i'm
gonna climb up to your room on the
eighth floor okay and then they would
fall off the [ __ ] balcony well they
they were getting drunk and jumping out
of the third story barrack window they
had
because a lot of the [ __ ] beds at
that particular time were empty so they
took all the mattresses off the [ __ ]
beds and stacked them up in a pile
underneath the window and were jumping
out drunk jumping out
you know pretending like they were doing
[ __ ] parachute jumps and [ __ ]
it was funny you know they're doing it
drunk hold on hold it hold it you don't
need
ah you know i'm [ __ ]
falling all the way down
yeah
but you get sick of it quick
yeah i'm already sick of it just hearing
it yeah
and i wasn't even there
uh zusia is it zuzia or zusia k says i
love your hair thank you very much this
is my favorite of all the wigs that i've
bought yeah that's her faker that's
that's my face
well like i said my my real hair is kind
of at a stupid transitional stage where
it's like at three different lengths and
i can't get it to like
behave the way i want it to so i'm just
like [ __ ] i'm just gonna like put
wigs over it until it grows out to one
length
uh rickshaw says cd walkmans oh my god
yeah yeah
well i had a cassette walkman and i had
a cd walkman yeah later on they never
had eight track walkmans didn't know and
that'd have been funny and they're this
big [ __ ] and it took a long time
before they were anticipated and it took
a long time for their aunt to skip first
one i had they would skip oh yeah they
would skip like a [ __ ] even if
you were because i would just be like
walking into the hole or something you'd
be like
god damn it yeah you had to like hold it
like super delicate eventually they got
andy skip where you can shake it like
that and it would be all right but if
you shook it for too long the it
couldn't uh it couldn't keep up with it
because it was buffering it yeah
buffering it
i remember it's funny that i had
forgotten all about that but yeah the
first one i had
yeah you couldn't even like walk with it
no like you walking it's like a record
player yeah you had to [ __ ] keep it
yeah it was like walking away the record
you could barely listen to it on a
vehicle yeah you had like you know i
mean it don't hit any potholes
and they were expensive they're like 200
bucks they weren't cheap they were yeah
i think i got one for i got one for
christmas yeah
yeah i think there were 100 i think they
were 100 bucks something like that and
then
just a year or two later they had the
annie skip ones
and they were like cheap like 30 bucks
40 bucks they came down quick
yeah i kind of feel like a lot of
technology
because i didn't even
[ __ ] man i was like still using the
cassette tapes
for several years after cds came out
because i just couldn't afford a cd
player but then they got like so cheap
that i got one yeah but you know
it was uh
um
when i was in korea [ __ ] i got my
first vcr it was made by a vhs camera
that's what it was and it was made by
gold star korean company oh yeah yeah
gold star was kind of like yeah they
sold the cameras and [ __ ] like that over
here yeah you could get it for like 200
something and they were like super shady
yeah
and [ __ ] i was amazed that i had a
video camera because it was 1991.
let's get [ __ ] videotaping everything
in the barracks i don't have any
videotapes anymore all long ago
and uh [ __ ] i would videotape dudes
fighting and all kinds of [ __ ] and then
when they'd sober up they'd go where's
that videotape it's what do you want a
videotape for no no no no where's that
video then they want to erase everything
on the video did you want to like no
this is blackmail material yeah they
want to face everything yeah
i got one with my [ __ ] roommate
webster was a big old black dude just
beating the [ __ ] out of [ __ ] taylor
with a [ __ ] rucksack frame hit him on
the back boom boom taylor was [ __ ]
going
he looked like them
taylor looked like a cr look like you
took gollum
from lord of the rings and [ __ ]
crossbred him with a [ __ ]
with a wither with a with a chipmunk
with a way to win it with a chipmunk or
a rat or something he had a little
[ __ ] teeth that came down like in his
ears
like that you know and he
he was so [ __ ] drunk he didn't know
where he was and just started screaming
and screaming at [ __ ] webster about
something that you know and it didn't
make any damn sense accused of been
doing something and webster started
[ __ ] get out of here get out of here
started kicking him out of the room and
picked up a rucksack friend he was
assembled at the time because he was
working on his gear just
they're aluminum they don't get away
anything hitting him on the back goes ah
he falls down
right he's not even getting up there
just like this i'm not videotaping i was
sitting down video
smoking
and i was like giddy
[Laughter]
get it did you get out of here these
[ __ ] webster's
laying the law down on him and he leaves
and then can you believe that [ __ ] i
can't believe he just came in here ross
ross i can't believe he came in here
like that he said you hit him you dealt
him you dealt it to him man you i [ __ ]
him up didn't it yeah you [ __ ] i
remember all that [ __ ] man
you [ __ ] him i did [ __ ] him up
and he starts ironing again i remember
that [ __ ]
[ __ ] it
webster was one of these dudes that
would iron his underwear
i don't understand that [ __ ] he would
just he would just get the irony
to be all warm yeah but he would just
[ __ ] me and sofino would be sitting
there going and shooting
hey webster why are you
why you want to iron socks
they got to make them they had that line
going down in front of them they're like
they're not judging you on that man
he's from south central he didn't give a
[ __ ] about [ __ ]
iron socks i didn't give about iron
socks either [ __ ] it well maybe he had
ocd just something iron his socks
ironing in his underwear judging you do
you if that's what you if this that's
what you want to do i think it was
mostly about him sitting there standing
listening to his [ __ ] romantic r b
movie music and [ __ ] reminiscent
about his girlfriend back like luther
yeah exactly
you know drafino when i get home i'm
going to give me some of that you should
see he's talking about her ass and [ __ ]
you know
she's going to send me underwear you're
going to send me
yeah i'm going to smell it you know
[ __ ] you know these [ __ ] are
crazy looking back on it he was funny
man webster
we lost track of him he went to 101st
with us but we never found him again we
don't know what happened to him never
fought i'm sure he's probably around
he's around somewhere murderhorn it says
showing my age bought my first cd at the
px the breeders song cannonball yeah i
remember that i had that um what was the
name of that album
that had cannonball on it i had that
whole album i think i got it
i think i got it for one of those
remember they used to have those music
clubs what was that [ __ ] [ __ ] called
where it started out with like cassettes
where it was uh [ __ ] columbia house
columbia house yeah and it was like
there was always kind of like ads and
the magazines yeah and then they would
send us like 20 cds for a penny or
something like that and then like but
every month they'd like send you a new
one and i always like forgot to so i
think i got it because of that yeah yeah
horn is that brown those brown underwear
those brown army underwear that's what
he was ironing why were they brown so if
you pooped you nobody could see it no it
was just everything was [ __ ]
camouflage color everything the socks
were green
so that was just a bonus that if you
poop no one can see it yeah i guess
we didn't wear them i didn't wear them
no one [ __ ] command though
but that should have ventilation
[Laughter]
fly free little testicles yeah just let
everything happen
open your fly your fly's just a bunch of
buttons just open it let it air out you
can't see it anyway
those old bdu shirts that were tapering
at the waist and then they had [ __ ]
you know what i mean they they uh they
had panels that went went around front
and the back
you could [ __ ] walk around just naked
and and not see anything
you know i mean it would be like a skirt
because they were long the shirt was
long you know
until somebody ran up behind you and
went boop and like looked at your butt
no most dudes most dudes were [ __ ]
went commando they didn't have any
[ __ ] underwear on because that would
just collect a lot of sweat and yeah you
think it would get all it would just
[ __ ] could get sweaty and it would
[ __ ] rub in between your [ __ ]
thighs when you were [ __ ] marching
and you're out there for [ __ ] weeks
and it would just
rub you raw so we
a lot of guys shaved and because you did
you don't have real toilet paper so you
just have to shave
um
the toilet you get you're living off of
mre toilet paper which is you know
things a little square about that big
and [ __ ] handy wipes
and body hair was like a bad
you know just dirt dirty
so we just shaved everything you know if
we were going to go out to the field for
a long time some guys didn't stay shaved
i i got in the habit of just staying
shaved
porn is ready ready
yeah
but going commando goes all the way back
to the [ __ ] 40s
it's probably a british invention
because they came up with some of the
first commandos
and they didn't wear underwear and
they're
just [ __ ] shaved it's just it's the
only way to stay clean for long periods
of time yeah you know but yeah you can
have a shower you can't shovel all my
hair cause like it just
gathers like yeah just gathers sweat and
dirt yeah it's just kind of like it's
hard to get clean yeah some of those
missions we didn't shower for a month
and wore the same uniform for half the
time only carried two uniforms one you
were wearing another one in your
rucksack you're out there for 40 days
in the field
pumping rucksacks [ __ ] every day
sometimes 20 miles a day
over mountains in korea especially team
spirit that was the worst one and
sometimes in sub-zero weather
so it's arctic
and
you just don't want any underwear and
you don't want any body hair you just
want to be able to [ __ ] wipe
everything down with a [ __ ] little
handy wipe it comes out of your down mre
tablet if you're real lucky you'll have
a roll of handy wipes you could buy a
civilian you seal it up with duct tape
so keep the moisture in and keep
everything out we had all the different
little tricks you know
and lava soap and [ __ ] hand towel and
[ __ ] have that inside your k-pop and
pulling [ __ ] hot water in there or
whatever and taking a shower out of that
because you didn't want to take a bath
out of your canteen cup because you
cooked in that yeah yeah so you do it
inside your [ __ ] helmet
yeah glenn says we're condoms camo brown
[Laughter]
probably not
all right so all right you seem like
you're
getting an answer for getting antsy yeah
he's always like moving around
you're like even not even in the frame
most of the time it's all right i don't
need to be here
i don't need to be here yeah
yeah i guess we probably should go like
find a movie to watch the show's almost
been on an hour
more than an hour it's an hour and 13
minutes man you got a bonus show yeah
yeah well i mean we would have done a
show today anyway but it's just that we
weren't talking about a movie we were
just talking about like random ass [ __ ]
but you know yeah because we didn't
watch a movie last night that's how it
goes so we gotta find a movie to watch
tonight something short maybe something
we've seen before or something that's
not to like i said it's not too taxing
because i did want to do godfather too
but i was just kind of like man it's
probably three hours long and i'll
probably like not stay awake for it i've
had like some coffee but it's not really
helping
i don't know but yeah so
we'll be back tomorrow
same time same channel
uh talking about some movie we don't
know which one it's going to be yet so
it'll be a surprise um but yeah so
thanks everybody for dropping by on this
memorial day monday
thanks for super chats
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
evening
bye